now the film limelight is about many
things but it's about narcissism and
Hollywood and you know with this element
of social media that especially everyone
in your generation is just they were
pretty much born into it what's your
feeling about that because as an actor
you have to do social media you have to
promote yourself yeah but is there a
time when you say you know what I'm not
gonna look at the phone yeah I mean it's
there are positive and negatives of
anything in the industry but especially
with social media I've so many people
say such wonderful things to me and so
many people who don't service will be
people you don't say dad see things you
on Twitter or whatever and you just kind
of got to put it aside and be grateful
for the people who are really nice and
really supportive of what you do I mean
there's instagram and twitter and i'm on
both I wasn't crazy about it first I was
a little later to get on Twitter and
Instagram the reason I I do it is mostly
so that I have this this audience so
that when i do have projects people will
listen or watch or tweet or retweet
other than that I mean sometimes it's
not really my favorite thing to do you
know I do it a lot just because I think
it's really now part of its ingrained in
the industry now and I think that it is
important for the fact that I I want the
people who follow me to know that that
I'm an okay guy also I I think that's
cool to show them on Instagram show them
like some be playing with my dog this my
girlfriend it's my family you know
important stuff to me and I think it's
interesting there is another side of it
though where I think that the
interesting thing that used to be about
movies movie stars and I think it it's
made kind of the whole allure of movie
stars disappear a little bit because you
know when there was James Dean when
there's Steve McQueen people didn't know
what they were doing in the private life
and now you have TMZ and you have
twitter and you can always find out and
that's something that's sad that's a
little bit lost I think it's I think
it's really fascinating when you don't
know that much about a person so I mean
there is a lot I keep off of it no one
will really know no elements of the true
me but I don't think anyone's really
going to know who I am ever
career like really know me because I
would rather keep it that way there's a
lot that I'd rather keep in my private
life which is interesting because I
think that probably only comes from
having people try to access you because
I see a lot of people the opposite maybe
they haven't had that and they want to
show everything yeah it's five minutes
from now look at this and is that
somewhat what the film is about as well
I mean I'm not sure yeah I think that um
an important part of the film is just
that it it's nice to see a story where
they kind of explore that where they
would they show you maybe what you look
like to other people it's kind of turn
the camera around at people you know
they're so busy so focused on on taking
pictures with their friends or taking
pictures of themselves that they don't
notice maybe what it looks like to an
outside perspective and at the same time
like there are like i was saying there
are positive things about social media
like i said i get to show that i'm an
okay dude i'm a family oriented guy but
at the same time i don't really i don't
know a certain parts of privacy trip me
out a little and i don't want to really
give up everything and I think there are
people are willing to there are people
who crave more attention than others
definitely and I think that's become a
part of it where I noticed especially
young artists my age focusing more on
that more on the branding of themselves
and really the the talent and this
project really explores that which is
cool about what it means to be a star
and what it means to be an actor and and
how people in the industry view and how
people outside the industry view it
you